So we'll need to save the name of the country as well as the country's
population. We'll initialize largest country name with the first country that
we look at, sort of the way we initialized largest population with just the
population that we looked at. Now when we find something which has a population
larger than the largest population. We'll need to update the largest country
name as well as the largest population. Now, when our program gets to the end,
where we print things out, it'll still have access to the largest and the
largest country name, but it's only printing out the population. So I'll add a
line, print the country with the largest population is and the variable where
we saved the largest country's name. When it asks for a file, I'll find the
population file. And I get that the country with the largest population is
Afghanistan at 3.0419E7. That seems pretty funny to me. I don't think of
Afghanistan as a very big country. Let's look at these numbers. Afghanistan has
eight digits. But Bangladesh has nine. Clearly there's something wrong with the
program. It looks like it's set the largest population and the largest
population name the first time, but then after that, probably didn't update it.
So there must be something wrong with my loop. Oh! It's looking for a double
first, but the format of the file has the name of the country first, and then
something that could be read as a double. So this should actually just be,
hasNext not hasNextDouble. Let's try this again. Okay. Now I'm getting that the
country with the largest population is China, with this as it's population.
That seems much more reasonable.